please be seated
I think there's some moving around of
chairs and so if you'll just give us a
moment to make sure everyone is
accommodated in the chapel who needs to
be
happy Mother's Day
seniors you look good
we've got another 20 people or so to be
seated so I'll give you the play-by-play
congratulations to the class of 2012
Exton stone above the entrance to earl
hall other words erected for the
students that religion and learning may
go hand in hand and character grow with
knowledge we remain committed to that
aspiration in a world far more complex
than our forbearers imagined each of you
each of you is testimony to our abiding
hope that we can come and reason
together today we are a community that
is not fully whole our general studies
seniors are not with us in this service
because of circumstances beyond their
control they're enjoying their class day
at this moment but we remember them Dean
on sends his greetings on behalf of the
GS community and Jacqueline thon will
join us to participate in this service
finally I want to acknowledge kaliesha
Hollis kaliesha throughout her
undergraduate years at Columbia has
worked behind the scenes as a chaplains
associate to make ceremonies like this
possible
Thank You kaliesha
welcome to this multi-phase university
baccalaureate service thank you
good morning assalamualaikum and peace
be upon you so I'll be reading a
selection from Mohammad Iqbal Mohammad
Iqbal was a Muslim poet versed in Sufi
poetry Islamic philosophy and Western
religious and political thought he
approached the world with the
willingness to constructively engage an
attitude that led him to develop a
framework for living that I find to
truly be impactful and meaningful for my
own life one that grapples with
difference without dismissing it
embraces self-reflection and sparks
personal and communal growth fittingly
he developed this framework for living
and his understanding of Islam through
an engagement with with a Sufi tradition
but also through conversations and
interactions with honoree Burke's own
and Leopold Senghor
Brookes own was a Nobel laureate was a
French noble or noted for his philosophy
of religion Sankore was a poet
intellectual and the first president of
an independent Senegal both men were
Christian despite the religious racial
and linguistic differences they all saw
individual transformation as a locus for
changing a world wrought with structural
inequality and violence it is from this
perspective that Iqbal explains and I
quote that religion is not a
departmental affair it is neither
neither mere thought nor mere feeling
nor mere action it is an expression of
the whole man it is an expression that
works to transform the individual as the
moral and religious ideal of man is not
self negation but self affirmation and
he attains this ideal by becoming more
and more individual more and more unique
by pushing ourselves to learn to engage
and to reflect we are able to transform
ourselves but also the world around us a
world that is animated by vast
inequalities but a world that can be
transformed through ethical and engaged
living thank you
to observe the Sabbath is to celebrate
the coronation of a day in the spiritual
Wonderland of time the air of which we
inhale when we call it a delight call
the Sabbath a delight a delight to the
soul and a delight to the body since
there are so many acts which one must
abstain from doing on the seventh day
you might think I have given you the
Sabbath for your displeasure
I've surely given you the Sabbath for
your pleasure to sanctify the seventh
day does not mean to thank to by the
seventh day does not mean - amor de that
mortify thyself but on the contrary thou
shalt sanctify it with all thy heart
with all thy soul and with all thy
senses as it says in the homolytic
commentary Deuteronomy rava sanctified
the Sabbath by choice meals by beautiful
garments to light your soul with
pleasure and I will reward you for this
very pleasure beauty of grandeur crown
of victory a day of rest in holiness and
in love and generosity a true and
genuine rest arrests that yields peace
and serenity tranquility and security a
perfect rest with which thou are pleased
time is like a wasteland
it has grandeur but no Beauty extrange
frightful power is always scared but
rarely cheered then we arrive at the
seventh day and the Sabbath is endowed
with a Felicity which enraptured is the
soul which glides into our thoughts with
a healing sympathy it is a day on which
ours do not asked one another it is a
day that can soothe all sadness away the
seventh day is like a palace and time
with a kingdom for all it is not a date
but an atmosphere it is not a different
state of consciousness but a different
climate
if the appearance of all things somehow
changed the primary awareness is one of
our being within the Sabbath not rather
than a Sabbath being within us we may
not know whether our understanding is
correct or whether our sentiments are
noble but the error of the day surrounds
us like spring which spreads over the
land without our aid or notice the
difference between the Sabbath and all
other days is not to be noticed in the
physical structure of things in their
spatial dimension things do not change
on that day there is only a difference
in the dimension of time in the relation
of the universe to God
the Sabbath preceded creation and the
Sabbath completed creation it is all of
the spirit that the world can bear in my
time here on campus the Sabbath has been
one of the most formative aspects of my
experience between running around from
classes maintaining internships and
being involved in student life here at
Barnard Columbia GS and C's our days can
be quite harried the day's flirt
together as we hand in assignments study
for tests and spend many enjoyable hours
in the library studying however I wake
up on Friday morning and I know that
today will be different than other days
because at the end of each week comes
the Sabbath time stops all the craziness
comes to a halt and I know that by
sundown on Friday my Sabbath will have
begun for me the Sabbath has been an
opportunity to break from my usual pace
as I sit back with friends enjoy of
meals together and appreciate the holy
day it is an opportunity to reflect on
the privileges in my life all the while
appreciating the grandeur of this
wonderful University and everything I
have received and accomplished here
hello how are you
loofa Cazalas the song I'm about to sing
I wanted to give you a little bit of a
translation the summaries that you are
aware of the song it's in Hebrew and the
song is about a little bird the mother
bird tells the little bird to go fly
spread your wings explore the world see
what the world has to offer but beware
there is an eagle in the sky
beware of the the trouble that you might
face but always know that the mother
bird will always be there if you need
her
Oh
Shepard's our ears
I shall be shy
there is thus no reason for competition
of any kind between reason and faith
each contains the other and each has its
own scope for action again the book of
Proverbs points in this direction when
it explains it is the glory of God to
conceal things but the glory of kings is
to search things out in the respective
worlds God and the human being are set
within unique relationship and God there
lies the origin of all things and him
has found the fullness of the mystery
and in this his glory consists to men
and women there falls the task of
exploring truth with their reason and in
this their nobility consists the
psalmist adds one final piece to this
mosaic when he says in prayer how deep
to me are your thoughts of God how vast
is the sum of them if I try to count
them they are more than the sand if I
come to the end I'm still with you the
desire for knowledge is so great and it
works in such a way that the human heart
despite its experience an insurmountable
limitation yearns for the infinite
riches which lie beyond knowing that
there is to be found the satisfying
answer to every question as of yet
unanswered Pope John Paul the second
fetus at ratio growing up I was often
told that I had my head in the clouds
and deed I was fascinated with the world
around me in the universe that lay
beyond me
it was this intrigue for the Natural
Sciences that led me to pursue a degree
in chemical physics for me there is no
conflict between being Christian and
being a scientist as Saint Agustin said
there is no disagreement between them
the more I study the more I was left
speechless at the glory of God's work
I'm convinced that God has no greater
creation
the heavens the celestial bodies that
are contained within them in the
universe that envelops everything seen
and unseen except for the creation of
man we are the greatest work of his
hands our destiny is greater than simply
becoming Stardust whenever I lose sight
of this I turned to the mass where Jesus
is present in the Eucharist in every
minding of his sacrifice to humanity
consider it pure joy my brothers and
sisters whenever you face trials of many
kinds because you know that the testing
of your faith produces perseverance let
perseverance finish its work so that you
may be complete and mature not lacking
anything if any of you lacks wisdom you
should ask God who gives generously
without finding fault and it will be
given to you we all know what is like to
face trials for the students here we
have been tested over and over by our
professors but for everyone here I think
James is talking about those trials you
face in life decisions you have to make
they keep you up at night doing
something that makes you grit your teeth
there's nothing particularly joyful
about these trials yet James tells us to
consider them pure joy it was the middle
of my sophomore year and I had settled
into campus life quite well I was able
to get a wean single as a sophomore and
I found God had removed all the
hindrances from reading the Bible and
spending time with him I wired my faith
to be stretched and developed and so
perhaps foolishly I prayed this prayer
God led 2010 be a year of trials so that
with your help I can grow in you and in
2010 God showed me how self-centered I
am how much I struggle to relate to
others and how prideful I was about my
school and my accomplishments and by the
end of my sophomore year I was so
challenged that I didn't even want to
accept the offer to become president of
my campus fellowship but that was the
lesson that God had for me life is not
about what I want but what God has
planned and as I accepted that I learned
to roll with the punches James shows us
that just taking exams grows our mind
taking on these trials and completing
them grows your faith and measurably
Chaplin Davis Dean Shaolin Berger
esteemed faculty friends and family
please join me in congratulating the
class of 2012
first off I'd like to thank Dean
Shellenberger and chaplain Davis I am
deeply honored to have been asked to
give this year's family tribute second
I'd like to wish all of the mothers
grandmothers aunts and if you are South
Asian like me aren't these a very happy
Mother's Day
I'm here today in front of you all as
the unlikely product of a long chain of
chance occurrences this story in some
ways starts in Hyderabad India in 1989
it was a time when my father had a
mustache bell-bottoms that he had been
wearing since the 70s a half-finished
master's degree and almost nothing else
despairing the difficulties of
supporting his new wife on a graduate
student stipend my father was ready to
give up his long-held dream of being an
agricultural scientist and traveling the
world he had resolved instead to become
a bank teller but it was not to be just
days from starting life as a financier
my father ran into a college classmate
who told him that it was the last day to
apply for Rotary Foundation scholarships
to PhD programs in America a rushed
application an interview and a Pan Am
flight later my parents found themselves
in Madison Wisconsin now it is apparent
to me that in the interim my parents
must indeed have taken quite a liking to
each other because a few days after
arriving in America my mother began
having morning sickness fighting what
must have been a rising tide of panic my
father first called a doctor who was
very helpful in diagnosing the situation
and then his student insurance provider
who was not helpful at all it turned out
that because I was conceived in India
and the insurance only kicked in after
they arrived in America I a human being
was a pre-existing condition
at that point it was cheaper for my
mother to fly all the way back to India
and have me there than to have the
delivery here without insurance so I was
born an Indian citizen now aside from
explaining why I will never be President
this story encapsulate how random chance
bizarre circumstances and fortuitous
decisions have combined to put me here
in front of you today this particular
story belongs to my family
but every person here today has one our
personal narratives in a sense emerge as
threads of the tapestry of our family
histories but that's obvious our
families have clearly influenced our
lives thus far here's something less
plain I submit to my classmates that
even as we graduate our lives must
continue to be interwoven in that
tapestry that as adults we must
acknowledge where we have come from
in order to give us some sense of
momentum for where we are going our
aunts uncles grandpa's grandma's and
most of all fathers and mothers are
really the only people who have any
comprehension of these fundamental
stories that shape us and without them
these stories probably wouldn't have
happened at all our parents have raised
us to be who we are sacrificing
countless hours and energy to take us to
soccer practices and debate tournaments
and even more fundamentally holding our
hands as children teaching us presenting
us with the incredible opportunities
that have allowed us to all be here
today at this hallowed institution we
are deeply indebted to those who have
invested so much in us in full
disclosure I might be saying all of this
just because my parents have not given
me my graduation gift yet
but in all seriousness college has been
a beautiful bubble where our
self-expression and experimentation have
been limited only by problem sets and
midterms but as we step out of the 116th
gates out of this beautiful bubble once
and for all
the only stable source of our identity
will be the people who gave us our very
first identity as a son or as a daughter
what makes families so compelling and so
necessary is that we live in a time when
we are constantly buffeted by the winds
of change we are saturated with stories
of revolution of progress of upheaval
and of new beginnings from the politics
of the Middle East to the agreed-upon
definition of middle age parents are
still young at heart everything around
us is perpetually in a state of flux
this is tremendously exciting for
society but at the same time deeply
destabilizing for us as people it is
more important than ever that even as we
engage with the world's problems and the
challenges and rewards of our personal
lives we fight the breakneck pace of
life in the 21st century
by focusing on the substance of what
makes us who we are our personal
narratives our families our ability to
do so will be the key to our sanity but
even if you accept everything that I say
and take this speech to heart by sending
your family members a loving elaborate
and heartfelt text message each day it's
entirely possible that on occasion
caught up in the whirlwind of daily life
you will find yourself walking on a path
that you're not quite sure how you got
to and in that moment you will realize
that the road ahead is less than clear
but before you take those next steps
think back to your first steps and the
people who were there to encourage you
guide you and catch you when you fell
realize in that moment that they are
still there ever ready to love and
support you know that
you are forever bound to that tapestry
of stories that in this ever-changing
and dislocating world you will always
always have an identity and a home
because that is your birthright
I love your mom and dad thank you and
happy Mother's Day
I hurried to the stage so I could adopt
some of that applauses my own I would be
a terribly ungrateful if I'd also didn't
take this opportunity to thank all the
wonderful mothers in this room and to
thank my own mother mama I love you
hopefully that gets me off without a
gift
two months ago during spring break I
spent several days backpacking through
the desert of central Utah with my
younger brother Joseph leaving our home
and Salt Lake City early in the
afternoon we drove for several hours
before arriving at our destination the
trailhead to a sandy path that winded
its way through a remote desert canyon
and closed on either side by stunning
red rock cliffs after hiking for several
miles that night we stopped a set of
camp and the next morning it woke to set
out on a seven mile trail that climbed
up off the canyon floor below deposit us
briefly atop a high barren ridge line
and then returned us to the canyon floor
below by noon we had reached the
elevated ridge whose smooth rock face
gave way to little vegetation but
offered spectacular unobstructed views
in every direction while the ridge lines
views were incredible it's hard rock
ground and lack of soft earth or
vegetation prevented a path from being
worn by any of its previous visitors and
as a result we were forced to rely on
Karin's small rock piles assembled
voluntarily by previous hikers to
demarcate the path we wanted to take
with no footprints and few other signs
of a trail we quickly became entirely
dependent on these Cairns to show us the
way over the course of more than an hour
we picked our way from rock pile to rock
pile often scouting out the next cairn
before venturing away from our current
one at times we could see clearly ahead
allowing for easy identification of the
next Cairns ahead of us at others
however each cairn seemed hidden
sometimes leaving us no option but to
move forward without the comfort of
being absolutely sure we were on the
right track
it was during moments like these that
our task safely traversing an elevated
Ridgeline that began to feel like an
island in the sky became somewhat
frightening for a moment it seemed very
real that albeit a small possibility we
might never reach our destination
as a tinge of fear began to set in I
became increasingly aware of our utter
dependence on the repeated appearance of
a small pile of rocks about every 20
yards or so for our safe return home
it has since reminded me of the children
of Israel's dependence on the daily
appearance of manna for their sustenance
during their 40-year sojourn in the
desert wilderness for a time manna fell
miraculous II from the sky providing
them with necessary sustenance but which
God limited their harvesting of two to a
single day's amount ensuring their
complete dependence on its repeat
appearance every morning had several
Karin's been accidentally destroyed or
misplaced we might have lost our way
just as ancient Israel would have lost
its necessary support to sustain life in
hindsight what Matt what made matters
worse was the fact that we didn't know
exactly where our path led except that
it needed to descend the steep cliffs on
either side of us and how we couldn't
really understand it would have been
much easier it seemed had we been able
to see the end from the beginning
however as in life this is seldom the
case as someone who recently applied to
medical school and will be matriculating
at the University of Utah School of
Medicine this fall I spent much time
considering the implications of every
step we take in life and have often
wondered why God doesn't simply reveal
to us more of what's in store like what
I should be doing with my life what city
I should be living in and and what steps
I need to take to get there while such
direction might be foolish to expect I
have learned to trust that God does and
will guide us throughout each of our
lives though often stepwise akin to
Karen's placed along the trail
there are many journeys in life and we
must begin without a clear understanding
of the end from the beginning and while
the end isn't always in plain sight from
the onset trusting the guidance will
come when needed most makes it possible
to muster the courage needed to
accomplish our own individual journeys
first Paul stated in this life truly we
walk by faith not by sight
today I would like to share three
principles with you which stem from my
membership in the Church of Jesus Christ
of latter-day saints or Mormon faith
which have helped me develop patience
trust in God and a willingness to act
that have shaped my time here at
Columbia and helped me as I've continued
for it on life's path and sought out
each new Karen placed ahead of being by
God and those who have gone before
first orient yourself and set priorities
even when we are unsure of the details
of our final destination in life having
the right priorities can help us find
our way when the path is unclear and the
consequences of each new step seemingly
unknowable when I arrived at Columbia I
decided that my devotion to God and my
faith would be my first priority one
result of this was that I decided to
refrain from doing homework on the
Sabbath needless to say this policy was
oftentimes inconvenient nights when I
had a midterm exam or final paper due
the next morning often gave me reason to
wonder whether I couldn't make an
exception just this once however I have
witnessed that setting clear priorities
and sticking to them has brought peace
and joy to my life
Klean Christensen a Harvard Business
School professor and Mormon has
suggested think about the metric by
which your life will be judged and make
a resolution to live every day so that
in the end your life will be judged a
success my challenge to you find that
metric and stick to it by keeping to it
you will never veer too far off the path
and you'll be guided when the way seems
unclear ii learned to trust to
compliment the advice commonly given to
graduates to the weary of tradition i
would encourage you to also develop a
deeper ability to trust the iphone
wouldn't have come very far had its
inventors been solely fixated on the
status quo but it also wouldn't have
been impossible it would also have been
very impossible to develop had they
completely ignored the laws of science
governing its future function I think I
had to throw this in because I am an
engineer we should never forget that not
all worthwhile truths are scientific in
nature
while God might not always tell us
exactly where to place our next step he
is sometimes explicit in his markers
that warn us from danger one such
warning that I hold is coming from God
is to completely abstain from things
such as alcohol smoking and coffee while
often surprised to acquaintances and
friends I look back with gratitude on
situations headaches and decisions I've
been able to avoid by heeding this
straightforward warning but why some
people ask because I believe God said so
and I've experienced enough happiness as
a result of trusting a seemingly
illogical and impossible rule enough to
follow it learn to trust God and those
who have gone before third and lastly
know that you can endure and the
Doctrine and Covenants a collection of
revelations received by modern-day
prophets the Lord promises for I will go
before your face I will be on your right
hand and on your left and my spirit
shall be in your hearts and mine angels
round about you to bear you up sometimes
even after doing everything we can to
hold to our priorities and trust God we
simply need to endure it is in these
moments that we can derive great
strength from knowing that God has not
and never will leave us alone between my
freshman and sophomore years at Columbia
I took a two year leave of absence to
serve as a missionary for the Church of
Jesus Christ of latter-day saints in
Frankfurt Germany during the many trying
moments the long homesick nights the
periods of exhaustion disappointment and
discouragement I came to recognize the
reality of God's unfailing love for each
of us knowing this is help me place one
foot in front of the other when doubt
discouragement and fear have threatened
to destabilize my path the ability to
endure has helped me and will help you
stay the course until the next Karen
comes into side I have worked with many
of you to increase tolerance
understanding and experience of
community within Colombia's faith groups
and you have all inspired me through
your incredible examples and diligence
so many of you have rejuvenated my
belief and faith in the goodness of
mankind and for this I thank you your
examples have made me a better Mormon
but more
kortnee a better person I challenge all
of us present to take a firm stand for
faith for tolerance and for action and
promises we do so we'll improve our
communities the world around us and
provide additional light as we Trek on
in our own personal journeys may we ever
trust that there will be Karen's in life
if not when we want them then when we
need them I would like to end with a
favorite quote the future is as bright
as your faith thank you
good morning as a unique individual each
human being is occasionally reminded of
what separates him or her from other
people in a community like Columbia's
this happens fairly often because
Columbia is so intentionally diverse to
operate in it requires that we interact
frequently with people who do not look
like us who do not think like us or who
do not come from the places from which
we come as a result we constantly have
moments in which we feel different I
usually experience these feelings of
difference when my involvement in and
commitment to the Episcopal Church came
into contact with greater university
life in the dining hall on any given
Sunday my shirt and tie would contrast
with the pajama pants worn by many of my
peers who had slept in for several hours
while I was at church this past Ash
Wednesday a girl attempting to be
helpful on the elevator politely informs
me that I'd had pen on my forehead and
seemed to be thoroughly confused when I
tried to explain what Ash Wednesday was
and who wouldn't hesitate to explain
that he is thinking of becoming an
Episcopal priest on the first day of an
evolutionary psychology seminar after
all Freud and Darwin didn't seem to like
religion very much and it is far more
typical for a graduate of this esteemed
institution to work at an investment
bank or the White House than a church
but surprisingly or not I have come to
feel grateful for these occasional times
of tension with the people and
perspectives that surround me I've
realized that I have benefitted from
those moments in which I have felt
different and in which I have felt the
need to explain myself my faith has
become stronger and more authentic
because it has required deciding to be a
person of faith rather than simply
following the status quo it has also
grown more sophisticated and inclusive
by learning from a larger community in
which many points of view are shared and
Express
figuring out how to be a person of faith
within a diverse secular context has
been an important part of my Columbia
education indeed I think learning from
difference is one of Columbia's most
fundamental values though it is not
often referred to Columbia's motto in
thy light we shall see the light which
comes from Psalm 36 speaks to the
importance of seeing through other's
eyes of learning from and honoring the
perspectives of others it tells us that
only through insight coming from outside
of ourselves can we achieve true
knowledge as a Columbia College student
I have seen this value in Freud in the
core curriculum in which students
explore a variety of works and ideas
that have shaped our society into what
it is today
through some of the greatest literature
ever written some of the greatest
philosophies ever outlined some of the
greatest symphonies ever composed and
some of the greatest masterpieces ever
painted columbia college students learn
from and add to a long intellectual and
cultural conversation between writers
thinkers musicians artists and
scientists well the core curriculum in
particular and the columbia university
education in general have taught me many
things i think perhaps the most
significant thing that they have taught
me is intellectual humility as i have
undertaken the journey of college with
classmates from all over the country and
the globe I have discovered that my own
thoughts and ideas are part of a vast
constellation of which I am only a small
part in and out of the classroom I have
come to realize that I am NOT alone in
the things I think about or in the
feelings I have throughout the centuries
and millennia and across the classroom
many others have wondered how to
establish the perfect government or what
evil is and how to resist it many others
have experienced what it has meant to
fall in love or be tangled in conflict
many others have sought to express their
deepest emotions creatively in art and
music to act as if I were the only one
who has ever met it
on the world's problems are lived a
fully human life would be to enact a
profound injustice to the many over the
years who have struggled to think and
live as I have and the many in my
position and in similar positions across
the world who struggle still why should
my view of the world have precedence
over the many passionate well
thought-out perspectives of others just
as I have learned that going to church
is only one way to spend a Sunday
morning so I also have learned that my
way of seeing and interacting with the
world is only one of many possible ways
to see and interact with it over the
next few days we will doubtlessly hear
over and over again about how important
we are how much potential we have and
how we must do everything that we can to
make a difference and change the world
surely this kind of talk has its place
and we do have the opportunity and
responsibility to use our talents for
good and to the fullest extent possible
but I think it's important for us to
remember that wisdom and truth can be
found in many places other than
ourselves and I fear that an
overemphasis on our own agency may
encourage us to forget to draw from and
properly respect the experiences of
others so I offer a different hope for
myself and for all of us a prayer that
we may truly appreciate and be informed
by the great thinkers that have preceded
us and our friends and contemporaries
who now travel with us may we never
forget what I believe is the most
important lesson Colombia has taught us
which is look to the truths that others
can teach yes we should continue to work
things out on our own to craft our own
individual pass through the wilderness
of life but if we let our own pass be
informed by the values and insights of
others I believe both ourselves and our
world will emerge richer and stronger as
a result thank you
you
does God have a blueprint for my life
father Gilbert Martinez the pastor of my
church the Church of San Paul the
Apostle asked in one of his homilies on
a day like today it would be easy for me
to say yes God does have a blueprint for
my life and it's a great one his
blueprint has me dressed in the light
blue gown walking across lo plaza to
receive my diploma from a renowned Ivy
League university in the great city of
New York on Mother's Day with my mom
sitting in the audience it would be easy
for me to say that because I just did it
20 minutes ago and yeah it's my proof
looking back at the last four years
though there were so many twists and
turns wins and losses lucky breaks and
misfortunes that'll be hard for me to
say that everything played out according
to some divine blueprint still I could
not imagine choosing a journey any
different than the one I've taken at
Columbia or living a life different than
the one I've built in New York City
growing up in a small town in Malaysia
in a town called Ipoh I've always
imagined New York to be this big glitzy
metropolitan city where every day is
like a continuous New Year's Eve
celebration and yes I partied like a
celebrity along with some of my friends
at the CSG Escala a black-tie event held
at Kappa Tau but I have also seen the
other side of New York I have met people
down on their luck coming to the
community impacts office where I worked
to get training on computer skills they
needed to get a job any job you can't
have the glitzy New York without
understanding and falling in love with
the other New York and I realize New
York City is my new home when I accepted
and embrace the city and its people for
all their diversity Columbia is no
different it is here that I felt
accepted and embraced for the diversity
that I bring I'm a student and now a
graduate of the school of general
studies a non-traditional school in
which every student comes with a
different background and have a
different story life story to tell I
myself was a professional ballet dancer
dancing at a contemporary ballet company
in Montreal Canada
before coming to Colombia I've been
dancing ever since I was 5 and always
dreamt of becoming a principal ballet
dancer at a major ballet company but my
dreams are crushed when I suffered an
ankle injury that ended my career
prematurely it is when I got to GS that
I met other former dancers musicians
models and athletes and heard of their
stories of triumph and setbacks I met
working students and learned about their
struggles as they juggle a few jobs to
pay for their education it is also here
there I've met veterans returning from
Iraq and Afghanistan who have shared
with me a slice of humanity that I would
have otherwise never known as I got more
involved on campus I've met student
leaders of different organizations
championing different causes and
sometimes with opposing viewpoints in
audio diversity I found however that
they all share an unbridled passion for
what they believe in an encyclopedic
knowledge of the issues to defend their
causes and most importantly knock them
dead ability when it comes to getting
things done
reflecting on both my work inside and
outside the classroom I feel pretty
satisfied of other things I've gotten
done I've chosen to get involved in
student government and I'm honored to
have been elected and served as a
student body president for the last two
years my goal was to Britt do a bridge
to connect the lives of gs students with
the Columbia community at large
Jia's students often feel like they are
on an island and want to belong in the
midst of the logistical shuffle to
accommodate President Obama's visit to
campus I received an open letter from
prominent student Lee
is expressing support and solidarity for
Jia students and the three other student
councils also offered a symbolic
financial contribution to help families
that have been affected by the change I
was touched by these gestures and
especially by the concluding words of
the open letter which states though
there are four separate undergraduate
schools we stand as one undergraduate
student body celebrating the experiences
and perspectives that every group and
individual adds to this community and I
thought in some small way this incident
has helped us achieve a greater mutual
understanding and appreciation for one
another to see us come together as one
undergraduate community was my goal
when I was four selected and I'm very
proud to be seeing the beginning of this
as I complete my time here now if you
had told me on the first day that I
would be representing my fellow GS
students as student body president and
standing in front of you to give a
senior reflection speech about my last
four years here I would not have
believed you when I got to campus for
orientation I was an international
student trying to fit in and trying to
find my voice I spoke English but not
America nice I didn't understand the
cultural references all the sports
analogies and never knew how to start or
jump in on a conversation
nobody except maybe my parents would
have thought of me as a future leader in
a place like Columbia then one day in
the middle of the night I got a phone
call from an orientation leader named
Michael
who was also at that time the VP of
policy for GS SC and she said to me nice
speaking with you about the American
language program issue at orientation
would you be interested to join student
council and surface International
Student Representative I thought about
it and said to myself why not so I
answered yes and the rest was history
but what if I had said no how different
would my life at Columbia have been
there were few more of these critical
moments of decisions that I could have
made a completely different choice and
taken a completely different path
whether it was a decision to switch
majors the decision to run for
re-election or the decision to say yes
to marriage proposal
if there is a divine blueprint I'm
supposed to follow then why am I asked
to make these choices at all I think
father Gill says it best God has
something better than a blueprint for
you here's an invitation for you to say
yes to Christ in every experience of
your life the Angels whom God sent to
you may not have wings but they do come
disguise as your life I have been
fortunate to have encountered a few of
God's angels in my life who have to help
me to where I am today I found my
happiness by saying yes to things before
I knew where they would lead me and I
have shared the source of happiness
by returning the favor and sending
invitations out to different people
around me I don't know if my invitations
have made as much of an impact on the
lives of others as some invitations have
made online but I do hope that I
introduced them to experiences that
would bring them happiness standing
before you I want to tell you that I've
no doubt you will do great things
after graduation as for me I don't know
how the next four years of my life will
look like but I know that I will be
starting my own entrepreneurship venture
called advisory to use the power of the
Internet to make available the expertise
that lie latent in the world so that
they can be shared with the people that
need them most I think what I've learned
at Columbia from my study of sustainable
development and economics gives me a
good set of tools and I am excited to be
working with a few of my friends that
have that I've met at Columbia who have
accepted my invitation to join me on the
entrepreneurship journey I want to thank
all the friends that have supported me
and believed in my mission during my
time here as a student leader and my
fiance Chris for jumping into this boat
and paddling with me the entire way I
want to thank my mom who is here today
for pushing me to do things I never
thought I could and my dad who can't be
here today because he's on diplomatic
trip to Beijing for teaching me the
value of selfless public service so to
all the parents who have supported us
sometimes by being there for us and
sometimes by leaving us to figure it out
by ourselves thank you
and to my fellow graduates
congratulations I am sure God has a
great plan for you going forward and
he's just waiting for you to say yes
that all sounds great but how's the
hello this is the question my mother put
to every tour guide at every college
that we visited as I hid my face flushed
with juvenile embarrassment not much of
a Mother's Day tribute I'm afraid
inevitably we were interrupting some
stock tour guide story about how the
students at this college go sledding on
cafeteria trays Wow this may have seemed
like vital information at the time but
in reality the answer to her question
was a far more influential factor in my
decision the hill at my college of
choice really had to have two things
kosher food that was not flash-frozen
and some committed people when I fell in
love with the double degree program
between Barnard College and the Jewish
Theological Seminary I could not have
anticipated the hordes of people the
40-plus student groups and the barrage
of food that the next four years had in
store but before I go into detail about
my life as a Hillel enthusiast I'd like
to take a moment to gratefully
acknowledge the presence of chaplain
Davis faculty and administrators
particularly Bernhard's own Dean hangsen
family friends and the class of 2012
Columbia Barnard Hillel was the first
Jewish community that I really
considered to be my own
I have probably been inside Hillel every
day a minimum of twice a day for the
past eight semesters to pray study plan
events and meet friends in this safe
space
I learned to navigate the highly
organized institutions of Jewish
communal life that will be my
inescapable destiny as a Jewish young
adult many of my closest friends as well
as a vast network of people I know by
face only have come into my life because
of my participation in Hillel I am so
grateful to the institution and its
staff and student leaders for the
opportunities it has given me but there
is a challenge and here it too being so
invested on a social and an
institutional level with any student
group it can form a social world so
complete and fulfilling that it
insulates you from the surrounding
community we come to this vibrant campus
in part to broaden our perspectives
through encounters and deep friendships
with people who do not share our
background the diversity of Barnard
College the Jewish Theological Seminary
and Columbia University affords us an
unparalleled opportunity to befriend and
to be challenged by people who are
coming from a different place than we
are on the other hand the richness of
our campuses religious and cultural
tapestry also invites us to do crucial
identity work learning how we situate
ourselves within our own communities
speaking for myself this process of
navigating the Jewish community has been
invaluable nevertheless in the times
when I have devoted the most energy to
my community I have felt the slight pang
of missing out on a campus loaded with
other talented and interesting people
each with their own stories to tell the
question then becomes how can we reap
the benefits of participating in our own
communities while making sure to engage
with people outside them on a deep level
to the extent that I
found an answer to this question it was
through my participation in interfaith
and intercultural activities on campus
the most memorable and inspiring moment
of my term as interfaith intercultural
coordinator on the Hillel board came
during a joint event with the MSA the
Muslim Students Association entitled
park51 reevaluated reza aslan on
Islamophobia and anti-semitism in his
presentation dr. Aslan addressed the
parallels between anti-semitism and
contemporary Islamophobia on a practical
level he talked about how the Jewish and
Muslim communities can support and
identify with each other after the event
our moderator professor Kamali
approached the organizers to offer his
thoughts he spoke to us about Rabbi
Abraham Joshua Heschel an important
modern theologian and philosopher who
marched for civil rights in Selma
Alabama alongside dr. Martin Luther King
jr. Heschel famously wrote of that
historic demonstration for many of us
the march from Selma to Montgomery was
about protests and prayer legs are not
lips and walking is not kneeling and yet
our legs uttered songs even without
words our March was worship I felt my
legs were praying
professor Kamali said to us Muslim and
Jewish student leaders that's what you
all were doing tonight praying with your
feet I would suggest that in context
this comment points to an important
truth about interfaith and intercultural
activities on campus and that is that
the value of a program extends far
beyond its content it is equally
constructive to have people who are
deeply invested in their own religious
and cultural affiliations working
closely together to produce something
meaningful be it a lector a service hop
or an ultimate frisbee game the
experience of collaborating with the
dedicated leaders of our campuses
diverse communities is one that I will
never forget it has enhanced my personal
religious life and hopefully
rich the lives of participants in the
programs we created together if these
events have enabled us to inspire each
other and to develop understanding and
trust between our communities then I
truly believe that like prayer they
fulfill a religious objective of the
highest order thank you and
congratulations to the class of
we are truly a multicultural interfaith
community I think it beliefs saw such
wonderful evidence of that today I want
to ask you if you'll join me in giving a
round of applause to all of our student
participants
will you stand with me and let's share a
moment of silence and moment of
thanksgiving please stand maybe each in
our own way give thanks
may God be with each of us amen please
be seated
as seniors recess from the baccalaureate
service student speakers Dean's will
lead us out and we ask that you will
greet them on the chapel walk as you
pass through the the line thank you